warum hat es eigentlich so lange
gedauert bis jetzt dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz in kraft treten
konnte herzberg und wer hat eigentlich
die verantwortung dafür aus ihrer sicht
wir haben alle miteinander im deutschen
bundestag die bundesregierung übrigens
vorher auch die ministerpräsident wir
haben doch alle die verantwortung dafür
und es hat ja lange diskussionen gegeben
es wird hier zum beispiel ist auch bei
der ausgangssperre etwas verändert weil
es der diskussion gab ist das eigentlich
sinnvoll ist das so hart ist das zu
wenig hart ab welcher inzidenz und ich
bin jetzt einfach froh dass dieses
gesetz da ist denn wir wissen jetzt 14
das impfen streitet jetzt sehr sehr
schnell voran
aber je geringer die inzidenz ist desto
schneller kann auch dieser erfolg ein
wirklicher erfolg werden nämlich einen
effekt zeigen und deswegen das ufer ist
in sicht haben sie gerade gesagt und das
wollen wir so schnell wie möglich
erreichen aber dafür müssen als erstes
die instanzen sinken
herr lehrer was bedeutet das eigentlich
dass wir jetzt wieder so viel zeit
verloren haben also die ganze zeit
erzählt man uns dass die situation
dramatisch ist und dann leisten wir uns
wirklich brutalen machtkampf auf offener
bühne und es passiert aber im grunde
nichts also es geht um wahlkampf von
panini bekämpfung übrigens richtig
letztendlich haben wir seit an seit
anfang märz eigentlich seit die
lockerung wieder eingetreten sind sie
wieder ein relativ starken wachstum und
das wird relativ stark ignoriert von der
politik sie sagt man hätte das nicht
vorhersehen können
aber vorher absehbar war dass
letztendlich und was wir jetzt sehen
dass letztendlich nur ein resultat des
nichts tun was wir in den letzten wochen
aktiv praktiziert haben und das ist ein
großes problem was ist denn was hätte
ein schnellerer lockt eine entschiedene
reaktion was hätte die auslösen können
was hätte verhindern können
er hätte auf jeden fall die ausbreitung
also die weitere ausbreitung der
fallzahlen verhindern können wir sind
jetzt aktuell bei ungefähr 20 21.000
fälle pro tag im schnitt über die woche
hinweg also auch aus gelevelt dass wir
die schwankungen jeden tag haben das
sind extrem hohe fallzahlen residenz ist
zwar momentan vielleicht in einem
leichten parallel bewegung aber da darf
man sich nichts vormachen das ist auf
dem werth bleibt ich gehe davon aus dass
sie relativ stark auf wieder ansteigen
wird wenn wir jetzt nicht wirklich
dagegen entgegenwirken
diese ausgangssperre über die gerade
alle reden bringt die jetzt was oder
nicht kann man das messen kann man das
kann man das sehen ja da streiten sich
die geister natürlich sehr stark darüber
es gibt
hinaus habe die beispielsweise zeigen
dass sie sehr gut
eine wirkung zeigen aber sie muss
letztendlich und ob auf andere maßnahmen
sein das heißt andere maßnahmen ist erst
mal massiv greifen und dann können sie
die kontakte noch ungefähr um 13 bis 20
prozent reduzieren das heißt es werden
zusätzlich effekt den wir haben die
frage ist natürlich ob denn die in
dieser umsetzung wie wir sie jetzt im
infektionsschutzgesetz wirklich
verankert haben ob es da wirklich was
bringt es gibt natürlich auch viele
leute die sagen dadurch dass jetzt die
leute gezwungen sind sich mehr
vielleicht außerhalb zu treffen das ist
dann auch zu treffen in den innenräumen
kommen kann und eine infektion wieder
ansteigen aber die großen studien zeigen
eben das etwas bringen wird und was
bringen kann die frage wird einfach sein
wie setzt die bevölkerung das um haben
wir wieder neuen wert der plötzlich im
raum steht wird gerne auch peter
ramsauer den punkt mal fragen wie wie
geht es ihnen damit wenn sie sich mal
diese verschiedenen incidents werte
anschauen über die wir jetzt in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten immer
wieder gesprochen haben mal war es die
100 was die 50 damals plötzlich 35 die
950 dann ging es wieder hoch her sind
wir 105 96 blicken sie noch durch man
versucht natürlich durchzublicken wenn
leute wie ich oder mein freund kalli
ruhig sagen nicht nur kollege patient
nicht mehr durchblicken würden wäre es
heute den durchblicken ein alter
grundsatz von mir lautet wenn die
politik die ich niemandem mehr erklären
kann oder die ich selbst nicht verstehe
nur die ich niemals mittragen also
versuchen wir paul alles zu verstehen
und erklären zu können
aber das ist natürlich ein er
durcheinander entstanden mit diesen
unterschiedlichen sound und ich sage
ihnen herr lanz einer der wesentlichen
gründe warum ich heute bei der
entschuldigung gestern bei der
namentlichen abstimmung über das
infektionsschutzgesetz mit nein gestimmt
habe war dass diese inzidenz zahl in
meinen augen vollkommen unzureichend ist
wie ich aus empirischen überzeugenden
fallbeispielen aus meinem eigenen
wahlkreis zwischen chiemsee und
königssee daran liegen könnte nämlich
manchmal darf ich das ganze ja also
landkreis berchtesgadener land nein
gestimmt ich habe mit nein gestimmt
sie sind aber noch in der csu-fraktion
eine
21 kollegen aus der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion von 200
endlich mal so viel zurück ausgeübt
worden wäre massiv druck
dann werden dass noch viel mehr geworden
jetzt wirklich ganz sicher jemand wie
ich der braucht sich nicht mehr unter
druck setzen zu lassen das sind findet
ihr als zumutung wenn ich noch mal
fangen da gab es ein fraktionszwang
obwohl es offiziell keinen gab
es gibt ja offiziell keinen
fraktionszwang und steht sogar in
unseren statuten aber wir wollen beim
incidents wert bleiben wir also dass man
schaut ganz kurz die sachen mit dem
druck das interessiert sind
wer hat den druck auf sie ausgeübt so
allgemein man sollte sich das gegenüber
allgemein
naja die also diejenigen die ämter haben
die sich schnell war auch schon hat der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer
fraktionschefs und so weiter ist könig
sowie ämter ja auch alle gehabt für
einzelne seite der macht ist immerhin
ein die dunkle seite der macht dass wir
dann noch mal ganz persönlich ja aber
ich möchte zum beispiel ein working was
eine wortwahl die partie merkte gebracht
hat dieses jahr dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz ist ein ja zum
leben
also das hat mich heute richtig
aufgeregt als unser
fraktionsvorsitzender sagte man muss
dafür stimmen damit mann fürs leben
stimmt bezahle ich mir gedacht ja jetzt
habe ich mir gedacht wird mit nein
gestimmt mir vorzuhalten dass ich mit
meinem verein gegen das lebens stimme
würde so ein unfug
ein solcher unfall eine reihe von
gründen und erinnert der hunde waren
jetzt sind wir wieder beim incidents
wird sie haben mich gebeten kurzen klar
ist es schön landkreis berchtesgadener
land die andere frage komme ich nochmal
viel ja am zwanzigster oktober bereits
als erster landkreis in einen scharfen
total locker und ist seitdem im total
lockt darum seit über einem halben jahr
das muss man sich mal vorstellen und der
grund waren hohe inzidenz zahlen und
jetzt sagen dass es empirische beispiel
da wird natürlich gemessen getestet
getestet auf teufel komm raus
eine zahl aus dem februar süß jetzt eine
zahl von bayerischen
gesundheitsministerium der landkreis
berchtesgadener land hat im februar aber
es war im jahr zum april wahrscheinlich
analog
im februar im durchschnitt etwa 1400
testungen pro tag gerechnet auf 100000
einwohner also so eine art analog
inzidenz wird bei testungen 1400 tonnen
pro tag und 100.000 einwohner
die analoge zahl in mehreren anderen
bayerischen landkreisen oberbayerischen
landkreisen waren 40 bis 50 testungen
pro tag
es ist natürlich völlig klar wenn ich
nicht 40 oder 50 sondern 1400 auch wegen
der einpendler vom land salzburg her
6.500 tägliche ein und auspendler bin
ich so viel teste ist ja klar natürlich
auch viel jetzt ist doch vollkommen klar
dass ich wahnsinnig viel findet und
deswegen hinter das total mit diesem
intents wert der muss irgendwie anders
geschaffen die das argument kommt
mittlerweile häufig die lmu ihn auch
meistens weggerannt hatte und alle
bürger wird ja genau hat in einer
analyse festgestellt dass die zunahme
der neuinfektionen in den jüngeren
altersgruppen am 10 märz beispielsweise
schlagartig um 30 prozent angestiegen
war
und zwar zwei tage nachdem es erstmals
kostenlose schnellstes den apotheken gab
und die wissenschaftler dort sagen da
gibt es einen ganz klaren zusammenhang
sehen sie auch so beliebt
also es ist nicht von der hand zu weisen
dass natürlich durch mehr testung vor
allem den jüngeren gruppen wir vorher
nicht getestet haben dort jetzt auch
wirklich die ware inzidenz erfassen
die war in der ersten und zweiten welle
total unterrepräsentiert weil die kinder
vor allem symptomatisch waren und man
hat eben seit november nur die
symptomatischen getesteten jetzt ist man
endlich mal die kinder rein gegangen und
hat jetzt mal geschafft die normale
inzidenz in meinen augen dazu zu
ermitteln das heißt was wir da gesehen
haben es eigentlich ein anheben auf die
reguläre inzidenz ich denke nicht dass
das letztendlich wirklich einen großen
bucht geschaffen hat und irgendwie eine
dunkelziffer erhält hat sondern dass wir
hier nur das normale infektionsgeschehen
jetzt ab will aber trotzdem hat er am
saum recht wenn er sagt wir können nicht
einfach immer nur auf diese incident
schauen es gibt ja auch andere argumente
dagegen leute die zum beispiel sagen
eine 200 inzidenz kenne
intensivmediziner die so argumentieren
mit 200
die dance bei über 80 jährigen bedeutet
was anderes als eine 200er incidents bei
40 bis 50 jährigen weil die über
80-jährigen sterben und die anderen eben
nicht das heißt die frage ist doch
könnten wir uns eine viel höhere instanz
leisten das ist ja die debatte um die
ist gerade geht
wie hat das ist natürlich die frage was
wollen wir uns leisten und dieser punkt
ist natürlich ganz wichtig dass wir
jetzt durch das impfen auch vor allem
die über 80-jährigen jetzt erstmal
geschützt wir sehen also eine deutliche
reduktion des durchschnittsalters auf
den intensivstationen
wir sehen noch deutlich geringere
todeszahlen aber das ist erst mal sehr
gut sehr positiv das heißt wir verfügen
jetzt die patienten die auf den
intensivstationen auflaufen
aber was wir nicht vergessen dürfen die
jüngeren patienten die jetzt auf der
intensivstation liegen haben höhere
überlebenschance
das heißt sie bleiben auch länger liegen
weil wir es gibt eine gewisse
korrelation wer stirbt stirbt schneller
das heißt die für web verweilen kürzer
und dadurch dass jetzt mehr liegen
sliden hat es brutal
die sätze die so fallen in diesem jahr
das ist abenteuerlich ja aber dadurch
dass ich es anhöre aussprechen dadurch
haben wir in anführungszeichen ein
problem dass sie länger liegen und
natürlich auch länger diese betten in
anspruch nehmen und das heißt neue
patienten patienten die reinkommen
finden dann letztendlich eine höhere
belegung schon wieder vor
und deshalb müssen wir uns jetzt einfach
überlegen was wir denn wirklich wollen
weil ihr uns die jüngeren patienten eben
auf die intensivstation kommen und dort
ist letztendlich der ausgang ist auch
nicht immer positiv dass dürfen nicht
vergessen dass politisch zu
kommunizieren ist fast ein ding der
unmöglichkeit ist also falsch sich
sozusagen auf dieses eine auf diese eine
inzidenz zahl so zu fokussieren und auch
dieses ganze thema der ausgangssperren
so in den mittelpunkt zu stellen dass
wir das gefühl hat jetzt geht es darum
irgendwie leute einzusperren ist dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz an dem punkt noch
sinnvoll
ich halte es an den punkt wir sind
vorjahr andere länder im europäischen
ausland haben damit gute erfahrungen
gemacht mit dieser ausgangssperre ich
finde sie auch dass sie wirklich herten
hat ja wenn ich auch persönlich
vorstellen dass ich dann vielleicht nach
einem langen arbeitstag kein spaziergang
mehr machen kann oder nicht mehr joggen
gehen kann das ist nicht schön aber es
führt es ist dann doch ein ganz klares
signal leute bleibt zu hause und das war
ja auch das was vor einem jahr im märz
geholfen hat als dieses signal da war
und die leute sich daran gehalten haben
und man kann damit eben auch die
privaten treffen und dann weiß
zwischen den infektionen finden vor
allen dingen im privaten raum statt man
kann sie damit unterbinden
und was ich jetzt im moment wirklich
kritisiere an der politik ist diese art
der kommunikation wenn ich sehe dass man
sich jetzt auf eine ebene begibt wo man
sich gegenseitig moralisch vorwirft der
eine sei für das leben und der andere
sei nicht fürs leben ich finde dass es
eine debatte
so kann man die einfach nicht führen man
muss sie wirklich konkret führen sie
konkret führen wie kriegen wir sich
zahlen runter und sich nicht irgendwie
gegenseitig moralische vorhaltungen
machen das ist echt am thema vorbei wenn
man das tut ja aber es ging gegen sie je
für mich naja wenn herr nicht sich
langsam
sie führen diese debatte mit es geht
gegen alle die diese debatte auf diese
art und weise führen entschuldigung ich
wäre nie auf die idee gekommen die
debatte so zu führen
ich reagiere nur darauf wenn mir jemand
den vorwurf macht nur weil ich mit nein
stimmen würde ich gegen das lebens
stimmen der schüler muss ich das recht
haben dass ich mich gegen so einen unfug
zur wehr setzte also sie haben ich sehe
in ihrem beitrag wird eine
rechtfertigung für mich um keine
widerlegung danke ihnen herr gott aber
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir abends
nicht nur die inzidenz werte hören
sondern auch vielleicht freiheits werte
hören die politik ist in dem dilemma
abzuwägen eine güterabwägung für uns
alle als bürger stellvertreten zwischen
freiheit und gesundheit und das in einer
lernen situation eines groß experiments
bei dem wir keinen masterplan haben von
woche zu woche kommt neues wissen dazu
und das ganze funktioniert nur unter
bedingungen des kuratierten regierens
das heißt also ich appellativen
anordnungen nicht einfach eine
verordnung der wir uns alle fügen
sondern wir machen mit seit monaten und
wer diese linie überschreitet das meer
nicht mehr an uns auch an unsere
freiheit gleichermaßen denkt dass wir
freiwillig mitmachen wird gar nichts
erreichen aber es gibt nicht das eine
rezept und ich finde die politik ist gut
beraten diese unterschiede auch intensiv
zu diskutieren weil die güterabwägung
wach die politik zum legitimierten
format am ende mit mehrheit darüber
abzustimmen aber wir haben kein vorrecht
für
gesundheit im grundgesetz dass es ist
einfach so insofern glaube ich dass die
übersetzungsleistung die politik bringen
muss auch immer davon ausgeht dass wir
bürger mitmachen bisher haben wir
vernommen bestimmt mitgemacht haben es
verstanden wir müssen
insofern auch erklärt bekommen wo der
fortschritt dieses neuen gesetzes liegen
könnte dass mir die argumente
nachvollziehen finde nur wir diskutieren
jetzt wirklich seit fünf wochen darüber
und seit wochen wissen ja dass wir diese
ausgangssperre eigentlich brauchen und
hätten wir sie vor fünf wochen
reingehauen dann wenn wir jetzt schon
wieder raus ja in der jahreszeit in der
es heller wird und dass das finde ich
ist das problem ja man muss es
diskutieren aber ich finde dass wir mehr
diskutieren als dass wir handeln und das
ist das problem und deshalb gehen die
inzidenz werte hoch wird gern noch mal
auf den punkt bevor wir gleich nochmal
der einsteigen herzlich merken wie haben
sie denn gestimmt haben sie dafür oder
dagegen gestimmt
ich habe dafür gestimmt
aus tiefer überzeugung oder haben sie da
auch ein bauchgrummeln oder wurde druck
auf sie ausgeübt wurde dritter er war
selber hat roth geht da herzlich lädt er
herzliche grüße ich hoffe also ich bin
ich bin jemand der überzeugend zu
überzeugen versucht keinen druck ausübt
sondern gute argumente
ich habe dafür gestimmt ich brauchte
auch keiner überzeugen ich halte es
jetzt für richtig denn es gibt dafür
auch gute gründe auf übrigens bei der
inzidenz das kommt ja daher der frage
nämlich wie können wir diejenigen die am
krankenbett ihren kontakten
nachverfolgen und wenn wir jetzt
erfolgreich sind dann tritt eben der
erfolg des impfens viel schneller zu
tage als wenn wir jetzt noch warten
armin laschet hat es ja vorgeschlagen
ostern jetzt lockdown das wäre das
richtige gewesen aber jetzt bin ich froh
dass wir das bundesgesetz haben und dann
noch mal der punkt also sie haben
möglicherweise gedrückt herr ramsauer
fühlt sich gedrückt also das heißt ist
eine eine eine ungute situation die der
offensichtlich entstand ist wäre es
anders ausgegangen wenn sie ihn nicht
gedrückt worden werden von
irgendjemandem als wäre es natürlich
auch nicht anders ausgegangen ist
vollkommen klar ist
ein abstimmungsverhalten ist bei mir
keine trotzreaktion auf irgendetwas ich
empfinde das nicht als unangenehm weil
ich in meiner langen politischen
laufbahn schon alle aggregatzustände
erlebt habe und zigfache erlebt habe und
david held und sowas einfach ans meer
war glaubens werden wenn sich wenn es
vielleicht mehr als 21 gewesen die
dagegen gestimmt ja möglich
möglicherweise schon aber ich ich
beneide diese kolleginnen und kollegen
nicht die also jetzt nämlich auch mal
das wort drücken heraus damit dass weg
ist die diese überzeugungsarbeit leisten
müssen und möglichst alle an bord halten
müssen um führen müssen
ich kenne das ja aus eigener jahre
jahrelange erfahrung wenn man selbst
diese entlastet ich wünsche auch
überhaupt der führung nicht schwer
machen habe ich habe ich kann ja aber es
ist ja sehr guten gründen für dich als
sehr guten gründen und dieses eine
beispiel was ich gemacht habe war ein
beispiel dafür aber noch nicht mal der
wesentlichste grund sondern soll ich sie
auf die fährte geführt
sie haben den ball in den himmel ihr
bild zu benutzen
ob sie haben das tor aufgemacht das
haben die letzte woche gesagt schulden
tor der schotten tor
sie sind jetzt durch gewonnen so und in
diesem fall haben sich alle schüler ist
durchgegangen etwas was denn wer von
einer der ganz wesentlichen punkte
das was wir da alle erwartungen an
maßnahmen das können ja die bundesländer
seit langem heute schon alles machen es
richtig alles bin ich wenn ich höre die
politik muss handeln
ja das frage ich mich entschuldigung
welche politik die länder können alle
maßnahmen ergreifen die haben alles in
der hand und bin jetzt sozusagen den
ländern die kompetenz mehr oder weniger
genommen und auf die bundesebene
verlagert wird dann ist das ein ganz
eine ganz klare tendenz von der
föderalen bundesstaatlichen struktur hin
zu einer zentralen staatlichen struktur
und ich habe in meinem politischen
gerade als bundesminister ich habe den
segen des föderalismus reichlich
kennengelernt aber auch dem fluch des
für
es muss mir ist das siegen des
föderalismus immer lieber dass die
kommunen um die länder immer besser
wissen eigentlich was zu tun ist und die
schlussfolgerung lautet die pandemie
betroffen ich bald restlos vorbei sein
aber diese tendenz vom föderalen
bundesstaat hin zu zentral staatlichen
strukturen das wird bleiben
und deswegen ist dieses gesetz ein
schlechtes beispiel für künftige
gestaltung auf gott muss man ja mal
sagen dass nicht der bund das ganze an
sich gezogen hat sondern dass die länder
nicht mehr in der lage waren selber die
verantwortung zu übernehmen sie haben ja
recht wenn sie sagen und hoffe die
hunderten die hunderter inzidenz hätten
die länder seit dem dritten märz
durchsetzen können nämlich die notbremse
ziehen in dem moment wo die hunderter
incidence überschritten wird und dazu
hatten die länder nicht die kraft nicht
den mumm nicht die politischen selber
selber selber angst vor der eigenen
courage in ihren ländern das
durchzusetzen was sie in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschlossen
hatten und deshalb ein offenbarungseid
für die länder haben sie das ganze
abgegeben
an den boden wo jetzt stellt sich eben
raus dann der bundestag
der winter hat das gemacht wird die
schneller als change dass sie in hamburg
gemacht die sind einfach nicht mehr
gekommen während der ausgangssperre
verhängt er war er war erfolgreich damit
und die frage an herrn ramsauer wer er
wirklich warum machen ist denn die
länder eigentlich nicht sie haben schon
richtig gesagt sie hätten es eigentlich
machen können haben es nicht gemacht
es musste jetzt einfach mal eine klare
direktive von oben kommen und ich glaube
das ist wichtiger für die bevölkerung
das ist zumindest mein verständnis weil
die völlige konfusion einfach herrscht
weil keiner weiß welche regeln gelten
und warum in dem einen bundesland das
eine erlaubt das mit dem anderen das
andere und mich verwirrt dass allein
schon und ich kann mir vorstellen viele
andere auch und hier in hamburg wurde
das erfolgreich umgesetzt dann kann man
das messen denn den erfolg dieser
hamburger ausgangssperre können sie das
messer als modell ihrer die ja das kann
man schon sehen wie viel prozent das
lässt sich jetzt das ist ein bisschen
schwierig weil wir diese osterfeiertage
dazwischen hatten da sind ein bisschen
eisprung also eier sprung im sinne von
springende kurven ja wir wissen genau
was da wirklich passiert das aber wir
sehen auf jeden fall ein anhalten des
anstiegs im vergleich zu anderen
bundesländern haben wir hier wirklich
auf jeden fall eine leichte reduktion
der inzidenz und ist auf jeden fall ein
gutes ergebnis
was ist das denn er konnte was wir dann
da sie
ist das 1 1 eine show veranstaltung ist
das ein spektakel für wen und für was
nein es ist der versuch in der
ausnahmesituation adäquat nachzusteuern
wir haben eine ausnahme zeit versuchen
demokratisch zu regieren wir als bürger
sind daran interessiert dass parlamente
beteiligt werden nicht nur regierungen
einfach entscheidend und dann muss man
sehen es gibt keinen es gibt den
epidemischen notfall aber keine
gesetzgebung dafür
insofern muss jetzt in irgendeiner weise
nachgesteuert werden und das wird mit
diesem mit dem hilfsmittel des
infektionsschutzgesetzes gemacht aber in
wirklichkeit sehen wir natürlich dass
die kraft des dezentralen was er
ramsauer sagt schon sich sehr bewährt
hat über viele monate weil die
unterschiedlichkeit die
verschiedenartigkeit man muss sie
natürlich kommunizieren
schon dafür spricht auch unterschiedlich
zu agieren dass in mecklenburg
vorpommern anders zu agieren wäre als im
saarland gibt es einfach von der lage
her und wir steuern also nach im sinne
der gesetzgebung in einer
ausnahmesituation und ich glaube am ende
der pandemie werden wir auch noch mal
das grundgesetz in der richtung ändern
dass wir mit weisungsrecht durchaus eine
epidemische notfall ausrufen können
immer bewusst das parlament ruft hinaus
keine regierung das parlament sagt wann
es beginnt das parlament sagt man in
diesen das papier insofern keine sorge
aber ich sehe aber das ist eine große
unsicherheit der eisen so dass der bund
mehr entscheidet der ist einfach da und
es gibt es gibt auch eine verunsicherung
ganz zweifellos also das was herr
ramsauer oder gerade artikuliert ja was
hat das hat armin laschet dieser tage im
gespräch mit bettina schausten auch
gemacht weil sie ob sie die szene im
kopf haben vielleicht kommen sie einfach
noch mal ganz kurz zeigen
armin laschet hat es für einen politiker
ist nicht ganz alltäglich einfach mit
der nackten wahrheit probiert und war
sehr erfolgreich damit wir mal kurz rein
natürlich dass gründer bezirk das
grundrezept ja die inzidenz was schulen
angeht ist noch mal angepasst worden
da gilt jetzt 165 warum eigentlich
plötzlich 165 das wieder so eine zahl
die gegriffen ist und nicht 150 das
hätte man jetzt nachvollziehen können
das wirkt irgendwie wieder total aus der
luft gegriffen würden sie sagen ja wenn
sie es ändern
es ist ja jetzt ein bundesgesetz ich
merke nur in diesen tagen dass seine
entscheidung von 300 400 600
abgeordneten jedenfalls nicht leichter
geht als alle
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
auch roms tritt vors schienbein ramsauer
aber wenn 709 oder 18 wer momentan wenn
die sowas auch hinkriegen wenn wir das
jetzt werde ich fast zum satiriker jetzt
in die proportionalität mit 16
ministerpräsidenten plus bundeskanzlerin
bringt waren wir doch ganz schön schnell
oder paul es ging letzte woche los und
du stimmst du mir isu auch bei der euro
rettung ging es schneller die stimme
dazu dass das ist jetzt gut ist dieses
dieses dieses magengrummeln dass da
viele haben hätte das gerne noch zu kurz
ab binden
auch auf seiten der medizin gibt es das
ja offensichtlich mittlerweile es gibt
an den sehr lesenswerten artikel bei den
kollegen derzeit die haben sich mal die
mühe gemacht das fand ich wahnsinnig
spannend mal die intensiv kennen das
wahrscheinlich die intensivstation mal
durch zu telefonieren mit den leuten zu
sprechen wie jetzt beispielsweise gernot
marx intensivmediziner aus aachen vom
die wie er sagt wie schnell die zahlen
gestiegen sind mit dem märz gab es noch
2700 kobe patienten jetzt ins 4700 also
es ziemlich schnell
fast ein viertel der deutschen
intensivpatienten sind cupid kranke dann
gibt's tobias welte lungenspezialist an
der mhh also hannover der sagt ich
zitiere es ist wichtig gegen kuwait 19
zu kämpfen es ist aber unverhältnismäßig
undifferenzierte lockdown zum einzigen
mittel der wahl zu erklären
es ist auch unverhältnismäßig so zu tun
als stünde unser gesundheitssystem kurz
vor dem zusammenbruch so ist es nicht
die lage ist angespannt aber sie ist
nicht überspannt roms 2 einzelmeinungen
oder was ist das ja das ist glaube ich
schon schon eine gewisse tendenz so eine
spaltung die wir gerade deutschland bei
10 also das sehen wir zum beispiel beim
einen saarländischen kollegen sich dass
auch die einen sagen die lage ist sehr
bedrohlich die anderen sagen geht schon
und das ist ja das was in dem artikel
auch sich widerspiegelt ich glaube wir
müssen ein bisschen gucken will mehr da
wären wir da fragen die intensivmedizin
das dürfe nicht vergessen deren täglich
brot ist natürlich mit dem klar zu
kommen was passiert das heißt sie
schauen natürlich auf die intensivbetten
patienten die vor ihnen liegen das heißt
selbst über schneiders intensivmediziner
erschlichene können aber die 1 guckt
natürlich auch wirklich auf die auf die
aktuelle situation und die anderen haben
vielleicht die perspektive wie es sich
entwickelt noch ein bisschen mit dem
blick und das fehlt mir natürlich ein
bisschen sie haben gerade gesagt 4700
wir sind stand heute schon bei knapp
5000 intensivbetten und die tendenz geht
letztendlich nach oben und das ist ein
großes problem
wo ich auch sagen muss ja wir sind noch
nicht vielleicht ein anderer rande der
belastungsgrenze
wir sind in deutschland extrem gut
aufgestellt was die intensivbetten
angeht wir haben also europaweit die
höchste intensivbetten belastung dieser
34 betten pro 100000 einwohnern das ist
doppelt so viel als frankreich und
dreimal so viel wie in italien
da sind wir perfekt ausgestattet das ist
sehr gut da geht immer noch was das ist
wie beim auto wenn sie im roten bereich
fahren sie können eine zeitlang meinem
roten bereich fahren
aber die frage ist natürlich wie
langweilig wie lange kann ich daher aber
dieser dieser normale thomas voß von der
lungenklinik bethanien den moers wir
sind und waren zu keiner zeit am rande
unserer kapazitäten
wir haben mehr schwere kranke schwer
kranke patienten das durchschnittsalter
ist aber niedriger als vorher
es ist von 665 57 gesunken aber jetzt
kommt der alarmismus der
intensivmediziner der die wii ist die
vereinigung ist unverantwortlich und
unverhältnismäßig bei den kollegen von
bild zitiert ja wie gesagt die beiden
gehen da auseinander ich ich bin eine
frage von meinungen freilich sieht ja
ich kann doch nicht der frage von
meinung sein
die abschlusssitzung dass das kann man
vielleicht diskutieren aber ein problem
was wir sicherlich was heißt problem wir
können natürlich mehr kapazitäten
schaffen die frage werde sein wie lange
wir das personal das mitmachen wie lange
wird letztendlich auch das system das
mitmachen und das andere problem was wir
auch haben wir dürfen einfach nicht
vergessen das ist natürlich mit diesem
hohen inzidenz man diesen hohen belegung
wer auf seiner seite natürlich auch noch
andere probleme trägern wie zum beispiel
weitere mutanten longo wird situationen
und wir müssen uns einfach überlegen
wollen wir das nicht das verstehe ich ja
alles aber niemand von den leuten die
ich eben zitiert habe stellt infrage der
scoop it 19 eine sehr ernste erkrankung
ist dass man aufpassen muss dass dieses
virus gefährlich ist
keiner aber denen geht es sozusagen um
den grundton der da mitschwingt gibt ein
anderes ganz bekanntes beispiel
mittlerweile des rk ii am 12 märz kennen
sie mit sicherheit auch hat im
lagebericht voller einziges von 350 bis
mitte april gewarnt als über 160 und was
interessant war war an dem tag es gab
einen der sich sofort davon distanziert
hat wissen sie wer das war
das war genau der mann den man immer
vorwurf der reiter der apokalypse zu
sein nämlich karl lauterbach
er sagte das ist zu hoch das wird so
nicht eintreten und er hatte recht
das heißt was ist denn da dahinter ist
der ist will man sozusagen die leute auf
die art und weise motivieren noch
mitzumachen und die maßnahmen
mitzutragen was glauben sie funktioniert
nicht mehr ja das ist sie haben wir
coroner müdigkeit diese ewigen
alarmistischen aufrufe bringen nichts
also muss man schon anders uns
überzeugen also ich hätte das so dass
wir lieben praktisch das messbare
deshalb die zahl ja aber als mangel an
maßstäben und ein maßstab wäre auch
freiheit und ein maßstab wären natürlich
gesundheit und das zu definieren zu
beschreiben darüber zu argumentieren
dass geht verloren angesichts der
verschiedenen zahlen die einfach
willkürlich gegriffen geben und das
erklärt auch die unterschiede zwischen
den verschiedenen fachmedizinern
bestimmte im zu was professor falter
hier gerade als schuldige entschuldigung
herr korte wie konnte das passieren die
sind schon lange im geschäft daher kommt
dass viele professoren ja mein
ministerium artig 22 professoren und
dann bin ich jemand zu mir gesagt hat
ich habe ein gutachten von professor
soundso da habe ich gesagt oh gott da
komme ich ihnen mit fünf professoren mit
fünf gutach gegengutachten
entschuldigung
nein ich kann das nur unterstreichen und
was hier als alarmismus bezeichnet wird
und das empfinden auch die menschen dann
einfach auch als übertrieben und
irgendwann nicht mehr glaubwürdig
letztlich auch eine frage der
kommunikation was nehmen die bürgerinnen
und bürger eigentlich noch an maßgaben
zwangsmaßnahmen der österreichische
bundeskanzler sebastian kurz hat mal
gesagt wenn beim laut da niemand mehr
mitmacht dann hat er locker und auch
keinerlei sinn machen
ausgangssperren niemand mehr mitmacht
weiß nur in dieser oder der mann mit der
frau dann einfach mit geht gassi geht
wenn und dabei ist ja dann ist macht das
zwar nicht zulässig seien aber nehmen
lässt sich dieses mini freiheit leihen
dann doch niemand abnahm
es geht nur mit einer zuversichtlichen
erzählungen mit der man das kombiniert
in dem befristet angedeutet wird wann
das endet unser freiheitstraße hängt mit
dem impftermin zusammen sind wenn ich
jetzt weiß und würste und millionenfach
man weiß wann man games wird erhält man
es gerne aus noch soweit und insofern
muss das eine mit dem anderen kombiniert
werden wir planen immer nur diese fragen
um die die inzidenz förderung wir planen
weil ich nicht mehr die freiheit und das
wäre die zuversichtlich auch zu der
optimistischen staatsform die es gibt
die demokratie am besten passt denn wir
wählen zuversicht als zukunft er kommt
aus dem dilemma heraus also ich meine
wenn man sie auch diese diese fixierung
auf diese zahlen anschaut und eben schon
darüber gesprochen inzidenz ist nicht
gleich incidence ganz offensichtlich ein
dies ist ein relativ stumpfes instrument
wenn man so will man kann ja auch
weitergehend also sozusagen analog zu
dem was herr ramsauer gerade erzählt hat
wenn du als landrat dann irgendwann
merkst dass du in den kritischen bereich
kommst dann ist ja die versuchung
möglicherweise auch gegeben einfach
weniger zu testen und dann können das
leben weitergehen
das ist ja die andere seite der medaille
das ist das richtige aber dieses weniger
testen das ist ja so ein trauma ansatz
der funktioniert am ende des tages nicht
weil das wird dann explodieren die
dunkelziffer wird steigen und die
fallzahlen wenn hoch gehen die schweren
fälle werden ansteigen also das wird
nicht funktionieren
ich glaube wichtig ist dass wir die
leute mal wieder mitnehmen und abholen
wir müssen eine perspektive bieten sie
an das kann richtig gesagt und der
eingang war auch schon wir sind auf
einem sehr guten weg wie impfen gerade
sehr gut wenn jetzt in prozent geimpften
haben wir haben die hausärzte dazu
geholt als wir das letzte mal hier saßen
hatten wir ungefähr eine halbe millionen
impfungen pro tag pro woche jetzt immer
ungefähr bei drei dreieinhalb millionen
pro woche das heißt es geht sehr rasant
und sehr gut voran und das ist das was
ich sage wir sind gerade wirklich auf
einer ganz guten gerade wir sehen das
ziel lange schon vor augen und trotzdem
für manövrieren wir uns eigentlich mit
viel kommunikation wichtig wäre einfach
zu sagen wir müssen mal wieder ein ziel
vorgeben
und das ist wirklich in meinen augen
wichtig wir müssen jetzt die inzidenz in
den griff bekommen bevor sie uns aus dem
ruder laufen und auf diesem hohen level
es ist wirklich eine sehr wackelige
situation und dann machen wir ein
drahtseil tanz eben auch sehr großer
höhe ohne wirklichen netz unter runter
unter uns haben und jetzt zu sagen lasst
uns doch bitte noch mal zwei monate
durchhalten
und wenn wir dann 50 60 prozent geimpft
haben werden und dann werden wir das
sehen dann werden die instanzen sinken
das wären wir sehen die todeszahlen
sinken jetzt schon und die tendenzen
werden sinken wenn wir so 50 60 prozent
erkämpft haben und das könnte so im
frühsommer in etwa sein also das heißt
so juni in etwa wenn nicht diese
indische mutter jetzt noch kommt die
große sorge muss uns das machen ja also
vor kurzem habe ich noch mehr sorge als
ich es vielleicht heute hatte wenn man
sich ein bisschen differenzierter die
zahlen und die information anschaut
sieht man dass das eine so genannte
doppel muttern dass das heißt jetzt zwei
mutationen in diesem spot protein aber
was sie nicht hatte und das ist ganz gut
sie hat nicht diesen aspekt der
britischen mutante wohl dass sie eine
höhere übertragbarkeit hat also das
heißt dass sie nicht infektiöser ist und
das könnte eine gute geschichte sein
wir sehen zwar meldungen gehört dass sie
in indien sich sehr stark ausbreitet und
jetzt auch in england unglaublich
300.000 neuinfektionen ja ja eigentlich
dachten aber nicht mit der indischen
mutante dass dabei hingehen hatte 300
linien indien in indien sind die
fallzahlen durch die decke gegangen ja
weil die dort auch ein religiöses fest
hatten im ganges dann alle ohne abstand
und maske natürlich gebadet haben das
ist will man natürlich eine problematik
die wir an anderen ländern auch gesehen
haben wo viele viele menschen aufgrund
von religiösen ereignis zu sein ist das
eine und indien ist einfach also wer
jemals dort war ja genau man soll nicht
verarmen der heute in die unglaublich
beengt leben also da abstand kannst du
das vergessen privatsphäre
wer also heute einfach nicht dort muss
man mit den zahlen aber auch vorsichtig
sein weil dort natürlich nicht so
sequenziert wird wie beispielsweise in
england oder ähnlichem in england haben
wir letztendlich dann auch gesehen dass
die anzahl dieser mutante sich
verdoppelt hatten in der letzten woche
aber von 0,5 auf ein prozent
das heißt da sind wir noch sehr sehr
niedrigen bereich ok in deutschland
haben wir inzwischen ungefähr acht
infektionen damit
also ich für den moment ist dass sie ein
klassifiziertes legend of interest und
nicht in wellendorf konzern das heißt
man ist beobachtet sie interessiert aber
man ist noch nicht beunruhigt und so bin
ich jetzt in dem moment auch verbiegen
und ganz kurz noch zum schluss also wenn
du gestern darüber gesprochen es wird ja
ein politisches ende dieser panne geben
dann wenn alle an im angebot haben
für sie als wissenschaftler wird es
jemals einen danach wirklich geben ja
das müssen wir sehen im moment sieht es
nicht danach aus dass sich diese
pandemie wirklich abschwächt und die
frage wird sein haben wir mitbekommen
wir es mit dieser impfung wirklich in
den griff
das was wir nicht vergessen dürfen wir
müssen danach oder wir müssen relativ
schnell auch ein globales konzept
einfach entwickeln wir sehen jetzt was
in indien passiert wenn wir 200 60.000
neuinfektionen pro tag haben ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass dort eine neue
mutante ich finde die auch irgendwo
leben hoch es gibt mechanismen zeigt die
ist relativ groß wir sehen das in
brasilien ebenso dort sind viele schon
mal infiziert gewesen wenn jetzt erneut
infiziert also das heißt das ende ist
noch nicht in sicht und wir brauchen
danach dringend ein globales konzept mit
dem wir diese pandemie bekämpfen können
ansonsten glaube ich wird das wird das
ähnlich wie die influenza sein dann
wären wir damit wirklich leben müssen